[Музика]
привіт, мене звуть Ольга Мін, я
вчитель англійської, ласкаво просимо на сьогоднішній
урок, дозвольте розпочати його з дуже
особистої історії минулого року я був у
Лондоні зі своєю дочкою і сказав їй: «
О, чому не  ми пишемо листа твоєму
татові, він сказав, що це, і я сказала, що
це, коли ви надсилаєте інформацію,
ви ділитеся фотографіями історій, і вона
сказала так, давайте зробимо це,
і вона очікувала, що у мене буде телефон
у чоловіка, я сказала, що ні, ми  я йду на
пошту,
чому мама, я сказав добре, ми купимо
листівку, листівку, і ми збираємося її відправити
, але листівка сказала, але як це
працює, тому я повинен був сказати їй, що ми
збираємося  спершу ми пішли і ми
вибрали цю картку ми поставили її потім я сказав
їй, що ти можеш одягнути їхню сукню зараз домашню
адресу
вона сказала, що ти маєш на увазі електронну пошту тата я кажу
ні, ні, вони одягають нашу домашню адресу
добре, а потім добре вона написала
повідомлення для тата, а потім вона каже, але
як тато отримає це, і тоді я
зупинився на деякий час і я  сказала,
щойно ти напишеш те, що хочеш написати
на листівці, ти йдеш і кладеш це
в спеціальну скриньку поштову скриньку що
буде далі
вона запитала добре, тоді спеціальна людина
подивиться на всі конверти
всі листівки все, що є
там, і вони класифікують його
відповідно до континентів, на які він
піде, що станеться далі,
тоді я сказав, що потім його доставляють у
спеціальне місце, де воно йде на більше
сортування, а потім воно йде в аеропорт,
а потім є спеціальні вантажні
літаки  карбюратор, будь ласка, нехай
скриньки для
листівок для особливих подарунків і
різні коробки, а потім він
биться в Україну і піде на
склад і тоді людина
доставить його на пошту поруч з
нашим  будинок, а потім, нарешті,
листоноша доставить його на нашу
домашню адресу ні в якому разі вона не сказала, мамо,
чому б нам просто не надіслати смс нашому татові
фотографію відео, що завгодно, замість того, щоб
робити все  У цьому колодязі ми будемо
говорити про технології та про те, як
технології змінили наше життя,
лише кілька аспектів, першим з яких є ваш
газ, це, звичайно, спілкування, тому що
надсилання повідомлень, залишаючись на зв’язку з
вашими родинами з друзями, це все
про спілкування з пристроями  наприклад
, мобільні телефони, комп’ютери, доступ до
Інтернету Wi-Fi робив нас доступними 24/7,
ви не згодні, так що ми
доступні, я пам’ятаю, що був дитиною і
подорожував за кордон, коли хотів
зв’язатися з батьками, мені дозволили це
зробити лише один раз  тиждень, тому що сьогодні дзвінки були
надзвичайно дорогими, і якщо я
хочу поспілкуватися зі своїм другом, який живе на
цьому континенті, або членом моєї сім'ї,
який подорожує, я з легкістю роблю
з ними обличчям вниз або надсилаю їм
повідомлення, відео будь-що  звичайно,
спілкування стає легшим, тому що ми
можемо ділитися всім у соціальних мережах
з нашими друзями, тому спілкування
легко доступне і доступне
кожному майже кожному  так,
комунікація – це річ номер один, яку
я хотів зазначити, наскільки це
змінилося, а що зі мною зараз я
намагаюся навчити вас, і це все
про освіту, і те, що ми зараз робимо,
це
робимо онлайн-школу, яку ви хочете  щоб продати, як
це створено правильно, дозвольте мені зробити відео,
тому, хлопці, ось як це
все працює  зроблено в Інтернеті зараз ви можете залишатися
вдома ви можете бути у відпустці ви
можете вчитися де завгодно ще одна важлива
річ, щоб дізнатися про
все, що ви хотіли б мати Енциклопедія у вас
будуть всі рідкісні книги
в бібліотеці або досить дорогі, щоб
люди могли інвестувати
Я пам’ятаю, що вдома було проведено величезний пошук
книг енциклопедій, усі
знання були всі інтереси до фактів,
були рідкісні фотографії, які сьогодні вартують,
все, що мені потрібно зробити, це зайти в Інтернет,
шукати пошукову систему, вставити
назву a  Чи можете ви сказати
мені правду, коли вам востаннє доводилося
переглядати відповідний словник, ви повинні
були подивитися на слово, яке ви шукали,
папір, ви знаєте, що
переглядаєте всі сторінки, ні в якому разі ми не робимо  Зараз ми більше не робимо
цього. Все, що нам знову потрібен, це
доступ до комп’ютера або телефону
та Інтернету. Ось як ми
перекладаємо слова зараз, якщо ми подивимося
на глобальне навчання, я впевнений, що ви
чули про різні ресурси, де ви  ви можете
навчатися онлайн не тільки ви можете мати
відео не тільки ви можете читати випадкові
статті, ви можете підписатися і пройти
відповідний онлайн-курс про те, що вас
цікавить, будь то медицина,
харчування чи нова мова, і
отримати сертифікат  дуже важливо
не тільки отримати знання,
але й затверджений сертифікат, тому першим
аспектом, який ми обговорили, було
спілкування,
а другим було освіта.
Сьогодні я рідко брав би
книгу з картою, якби зупинявся
десь у хорошому місці, як-от Мілан чи
Лондон, але найчастіше ми робимо
це онлайн, ви переходите до однієї зі своїх
програм і просто відстежуєте, де ви бачите
куди ви хочете поїхати, і ви можете вибрати
будь-яке місце, яке хочете побачити, і воно
направить вас туди,
тому системи GPS і всі карти Google,
а також інші карти та пристрої зробили
можливим,
як щодо бронювання відповідного відпочинку,
пам’ятаєте, ми колись  пройдіть через
туристичну агенцію,
ми будемо використовувати інструменти для всіх прекрасних
каталогів із зображеннями. Я навіть
пам’ятаю, що ви ходите туди двічі або три
рази, перш ніж прийняти остаточне рішення,
тепер, звичайно, ми робимо це онлайн, ви
можете забронювати відпустку онлайн важлива
річ  ви також можете скасувати це онлайн,
наступне, що ви можете переглянути відео на YouTube,
або ви можете прочитати будь-які статті
про місце призначення, куди ви хочете поїхати, і
зробіть це, а мій улюблений — отримати
таксі Мені дуже подобається, як легко  доступним за
ціною, він нещодавно став завдяки
всім технологам завдяки всім
компаніям, які надають нам цю
послугу сьогодні правильно, тому зробити подорожі
та перевезення в 21-му
столітті найкращими за всі часи. Я дуже часто
згадував, дякую за пристрої 21-го століття
і доступність до всіх програм
і ресурсів хороша, тому першим було
спілкування, третім було б
прозорим і подорожуючим, а
друге правильна освіта, давайте рухатися далі
бути дівчиною в 21 столітті. Я
щаслива, що мені не потрібно нічого носити  більше
готівки зі мною, тому що банківські програми для онлайн-
банкінгу та безготівкові платежі зробили
можливими, хіба зараз нелегко
шукати веб-сайти, які їх
цікавлять, робити замовлення в Інтернеті та оплачувати
онлайн, що робиться легко і
зазвичай?  re надійний, будь ласка, пам’ятайте,
коли ви здійснюєте покупки в Інтернеті, переконайтеся, що
веб-сайт, який ви використовуєте, захищений правильно,
тому банківські та безготівкові платежі хм, а
як щодо доставки товарів, якщо
ви купуєте це на міжнародному веб-сайті, вам
не доведеться турбуватися про те, що дуже
часто ціна доставки буде вказана,
якщо вона безкоштовна, вона буде доставлена у ва
у кінцеву ціну, і це робить наше життя та
им легким, мені подобається, я сподіваюся, що вам сподобається  це
дуже добре, давайте перейдемо до іншого пункту,
який був би важливим: це наш
дім, я не знаю, що з вами, але
я вражений усім обладнанням, яке
зараз використовують лікарі, ви можете легко
перевірити будь-що, або ви можете отримати все їхнє
ресурси, щоб переконатися, що ви залишаєтеся в
безпеці та здорові, і, звісно, чому б нам не ск
зати, що гаджети, якими ми володіємо більшість із нас, це
розумні годинники чи
ітнес-тре
кери.  кроків на
день, які ти маєш робити так, мій
SmartWatch завжди добре нагадує мені, коли
пора вставати, коли я
сиджу занадто довго, коли пора
дихати, якщо я збуджений і я перестаю
дихати, це нагадує мені дихати
Ольга дихати  і я знову  як
особливий широкий, який я маю від SmartWatch
в моїй руці, коли він дає мені знати, що я
добре виконав свою сьогоднішню
ціль, деякі розумні годинники можуть допомогти
вам відстежувати ваше харчування: скільки ви
їсте, скільки калорій ви споживаєте та
скільки енергії ви витрачаєте  так молодці,
дякую розробникам цього
дивовижного пристрою правильно добре, давайте перейдемо
до того, що ми робимо, перебуваючи
вдома, але потрібен лікар, лікарі
можуть надати вам онлайн-консультацію,
вони можуть запитати вас про ваше
самопочуття, вони можуть дозволити  ви знаєте, що
робити, і будь-які подальші кроки, які вам потрібно
зробити, моя улюблена частина 21-го
століття
доступність – це розваги
Розваги є величезною частиною
життя кожного, скажімо, не багато хто з
вас пам’ятає, що
це таке.  батьки
знали б, що твій старший друг
знав би, і я б показав щось таке,
що, безперечно, наприкінці 20-го
століття, діти не знали б, що всі інші
можуть знати, що робити  o це
касета, так, ми раніше слухали
музику за допомогою цих касет, але сьогодні навіть
компакт-диск є, я знаю, що ви не
слухаєте компакт-диски, у вас є інші пристрої, у вас
є доступ до всіх програм для всіх
записів у різних  не забудьте
заплатити за це та касету, мій улюблений,
так, мало хто з вас це
також впізнає, але повірте мені, що так ми отримали
доступ до відео. Ось як ми зробили
власні записи сімейної вечірки, і ми могли
дивитися це, щоб це було  єдиний спосіб
записати твої спогади так, я впевнений, що у
твоїх батьків можуть бути спогади про
твоє дитинство на цих касетах так
до побачення з усім, зараз я впевнений, що твої
спогади твоя музика, це все в
iCloud, зараз добре, що ти хотів  щоб
піти на шоу, я розповім тобі, що ми робили,
коли я був молодшим, ти підеш у касу,
ти дізнаєшся, що відбувається на
цікаву дату, а потім ти
повинен прочитати про подію, щоб побачити,
де ти"  Вас цікавить чи ні, що
відбувається зараз,
тепер ви знаєте, що ви g  o онлайн ви переходите на
спеціальний веб-сайт, а потім можете побачити
дати, ви можете навіть вибрати їх заздалегідь,
дати, події, тип
подій, які вас цікавлять, а потім подивитися,
що відбувається, як правило, є відео YouTube,
трейлери, тизери  коли
почнеться шоу, ви просто подивіться його,
а потім, що ви робите, ви платите своїм
кошиком, ви вибираєте електронний квиток, а
вся історія займе у вас до п'яти
хвилин, а потім електронний квиток
буде надіслано на вашу електронну пошту  книги, і
дуже часто вам навіть не потрібно їх друкувати
, просто збережіть на телефоні, а потім
його сканують, коли ви входите в
заклад, де відбувається подія,
добре те, що більшості хлопців і чоловіків
подобаються онлайн-ігри, в яких я все ще бачу
людей  ігрові майданчики, розважаючись,
займаючись індивідуальними видами спорту або ви
знаєте командні ігри, однак онлайн-ігри
– це величезний бізнес і величезна частина
розваг.
кіно, ти занурюєшся
у світ 3D-кіно Мені подобається
звук, Мені подобається, зображення схожі на те,
як метелики можуть літати навколо тебе,
це просто чудове 21-е століття,
дякую за 3D-кінотеатри гарні
мінімум три Я багато займаюся домашніми
розвагами  і приготування їжі - моя улюблена
домашня розвага. Я можу розважати свою
сім'ю. Я можу розважати своїх гостей
кулінарією всі дні в школі. У мене
є книга. У мене є колекція кулінарних
книг. Я відкриваю книгу. шукаю
інгредієнти. шукаю рецепт.
для процедури і нашого робити це зараз ні
я приходжу на кухню я шукаю
рецепт або для натхнення я міг би зробити
це в соціальних мережах, щоб шукати, що
було б добре на вечерю сьогодні, тоді
ви зможете отримати їжу, яку ви отримаєте
тому ви замовляєте його, його
доставляють, а потім YouTube показує вам,
як приготувати дивовижну страву всього за п’ять
хвилин. Мені подобається, це така чудова ідея,
що тепер є чимось, чим я хотів
би поділитися з вами, подивіться це відео  o
ось як люди з різних країн
із різним походженням і з різних
культур можуть зібратися разом і створити
цей прекрасний шедевр хору,
поки я не побачив це відео, я ніколи
не думав, що це можливо
онлайн-хор, а тепер у нас є багато
концертів і безлічі подій у прямому ефірі, які
ми можемо дивитися онлайн з
екрана комп’ютера або телевізора, але
подивіться це відео, я впевнений, що вам сподобається
[музика]
після того, як ми обговоримо все, як наше
життя змінили технології  як
спілкування, подорожі, шопінг,
розваги та медицина,
наскільки вони
змінилися  книги ти ніколи не знаєш, чим будуть користуватися
інші твої технологи, ще
одна особиста історія,
ну мій день народження і наші
технологи  я буду допомагати мені
святкувати цей день я поділюся
з вами правдою раніше будь-який інший
рік мого життя будь-який інший день народження моє життя
я святкував його з великою
кількістю моїх друзів та родини, але цього
року я святкуватиму свій  день народження
в масштабі уявіть, що я влаштовував вечірки,
але тепер мій день народження буде в
збільшенні. Раніше я влаштовував великі вечірки на дні народження.
ми цього не робимо зараз гумовий
laranesha, який є технікою, синій, але мені
не потрібно пояснювати всю довгу історію,
все, що ви повинні сказати, це я писав ще
кілька фактів про себе, я грав
на піаніно, тепер ви знаєте  я більше не граю
я раніше жив в іншому місті
тепер ти знаєш, що я живу в Києві,
раніше я більше займався спортом, зараз я більше цим не займаюся,
раніше більше займався рукоділлям
добре я цим не займаюся  більше
використовується, щоб давайте подивимося на цю дуже
гарну структуру, тому що фактично  y до
того, як технологи з'явилися в нашому житті,
ми робили речі по-іншому, як правило,
писали листи, які ми звикли писати для
рецептів у кулінарній книзі, а ми
шукали відповідні карти, які ми використовували, щоб
дивитися відео, які нам не дуже
сподобалися  якість була поганою, повірте мені, добре,
звикли ще до кількох прикладів використання
правого ока. Раніше ми чекали тиждень, щоб
розробити наші фотографії, тому що зараз у нас
є цифрові фотографії, це легко, ми
ходили в бібліотеку, щоб позичати книги, щоб
вчитися цікавого  факти, зараз ми цього більше не робимо,
ми маємо доступ до всієї
Вікіпедії та інших онлайн-енциклопедій,
які раніше ходили до туристичного агентства, щоб
забронювати відпустку, тепер ми робимо це
онлайн ідеально
добре, тому звикли завжди слідувати
інфінітивом, наприклад  Раніше я носив
готівку з собою до того, як у мене була кредитна
картка, або ви можете поставити запитання за допомогою
цієї структури, чи використовували ви, щоб писати
листи своїй родині, коли ви жили
за кордоном легко, чи використовували ви писати, чи ми
завжди можемо зробити не  від’ємне речення,
наприклад, він не використовував для перевірки його
пульсу, поки ви не дали йому фітнес-
трекер, очевидно, ви віддаєте його
члену вашої сім’ї своїм батькам або
другові, і ваш друг продовжує перевіряти його
так, я знаю, що буває, сльози час давайте
подивіться, як ви можете реалізувати цю структуру
добре Senton це мій друг вільно володійте
французькою, коли вона була дитиною, у вас є 20
секунд, щоб дати правильну відповідь так,
звичайно, мій друг вільно володів
французькою, коли вона була дитиною, яка проблема
розмовляти  про друга, який раніше жив
у Франції або ходив до французької
школи, добре, тепер давайте зробимо заперечне
речення подивимося на дошку
Алекс не любить шоколад, але тепер він
так, давайте перевіримо правильну відповідь. Алекс
не любив шоколад  але тепер він
це робить, і третє, чи
можемо ми поставити питання, будь ласка,
він цікавиться ІТ так,
чи цікавився він раніше ITI,
заохочуйте вас, хлопці, поділитися з
друзями, щоб поділитися з вчителями
тим, що  Ви звикли пам'ятати,
що структура зазвичай використовується, коли ми
говоримо про наш минулий досвід, але
те, що ми більше не робимо,
добре мої п'ять, які були вони, коли я
грав на піаніно, коли я жив в іншому
місті,
колись  займатися більше спортом. Раніше я використовував
кулінарні книги, і раніше у мене були готівка
, але це було багато років тому,
тепер ми працюємо безготівково, тепер ви дивитеся
кілька чудових відео про технології,
як вони несподівано змінили наше життя,
технології, де ми
їх бачимо в цих  відео там, де
ми ніколи не думали, ми їх побачимо
так, показ мод
[Музика]
Я впевнений, що вам сподобалися відео, будь ласка,
поділіться з нами моїми відео, і
дуже дякую за сьогоднішній урок, ми будемо
розвивати більше словникового запасу  grammar
technology дивитися, як наступного разу дякую тобі
до побачення
[Музика].